so I got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys asking
about how I make my videos and if I have
a team of people that help me now I hate
spending money until I'm making money
and it's so easy to spend money anybody
can spend money it's hard to make money
and so when I'm trying out new projects
investing in new things I'll always put
my time but I won't put my dollars until
i see that is making me something so
when i first started my youtube channel
i didn't spend anything i had my old
flip camera that i just put on a shelf
and i pressed record and I filmed it
myself I edited it myself sometimes
you'll see the camera is kind of shaking
and I used windows movie maker which is
a pretty simple easy-to-use program and
that's how I got started everything
myself and it's important I think to do
these things because it helps you figure
out the way to make money and also if
you're going to be committed to this or
not because there's a lot of projects
that we may start and then once we get
into it like I'm not going to keep doing
that and I could have gone out and
bought a camera bought a tripod bought a
microphone all of that stuff and and it
just sits there in the corner because I
gave up on the projects I wanted to make
sure I was committed to it and you
should too from there I moved up and I
use my DSLR camera and then I started
going through various costco cameras
started getting more and more expensive
as i as i want and i was editing
everything myself I got a tripod that I
used and I put a a sony camera on the
the biggest complaint i got from my
earliest videos was that there was a bad
sound because i was using the microphone
from the camera to record me and so the
sound quality wasn't great so there was
one costco camera that had an external
microphone jack so i got that one I like
Costco because it was a 90 day return
policy so if I didn't like it or I
couldn't use it or wasn't working for me
I could always take it back and get
something else where most of the stores
were seven to 14 days so less time so i
got this camera that had external
microphone i went to sony store bought a
microphone that i use here it's a
clip-on mic i think you can kind of see
it here and for a while that was my
process then I realized that the
bottleneck was going to be the editing
it's like a lot of time to edit these
videos
and I I reached out and found somebody
to edit my videos and since hired
somebody new and christina is now those
all my video editing hey Christina great
job and I found that helpful because you
got to think as an entrepreneur as you
grow a project that you're working on
what's the best use of your time for me
being in front of the camera that's good
that's good use of my time editing the
videos where I'm not good at editing and
you don't you know see anything special
for me I'm not skilled at it I don't
love it that's not a good use of my time
so make sense to give that to somebody
who loves videos and Christina does and
she does a great job for me so that
helped offset a lot of my my time it
cost me some money to do it but as I
started making money with my videos then
I could afford to do that I recently
just upgraded my camera so now I use
that costco camera was maybe five
hundred bucks four hundred bucks in that
range and Christina there's a whole
bunch of fun effects on these videos now
where she zooms in on my face and zooms
back out and pains and all this fun
stuff with the camera and it's all from
one take I'm not setting up different
angles that's all Kristina's magic and
the problem was when she zoomed in with
my old camera the quality cut and so the
next step was to get a better quality
cameras i just bought a new canon camera
it costs about two thousand dollars and
everything else is still it's me I come
I'm you know set up the the office i got
my tripod microphone camera press record
good to go and then I send the videos to
Christina and she'll edit everything put
the intro the music that all the cuts
the exit and she'll post it to my
youtube channel so it's a better use of
our time I guess effectively so I'm
doing more the stuff I should be doing
the two biggest backlogs I face now and
I'll have to figure out what i'm going
to do as I go along one is even the
setting up and everything takes
sometimes convenient because I can do it
at my home where at my office but I
might at some point get to having a
video crew doing it so I just have to
show up and talk instead of setting it
up the setup isn't that crazy but it
still takes a little bit of time and the
bigger one is the comments and this is
actually my biggest struggle right now
with my youtube videos because I get so
many comments
I love the comments keep them coming in
it's the best part of my day every
response is from me it's me personally
going through the comments and
responding to people even if it's just a
happy face just to acknowledge that you
left a message that takes me 45 minutes
to an hour now this morning it took me
an hour to get back to everybody's
comments and i love it but then I look
at oh I just lost so much time doing
this and so I don't know I don't know
what I'm going to do you know if you
look at the most successful people on
YouTube they're not answering every
comment so I might have to get to that I
really don't want to because i love
responding to you guys but i don't know
we'll see i had that issue with email
too i got a ton of email i get a ton of
tweets and everything i have a team but
but the communication part i like it to
be me like if I tweet you that's me if I
respond to your comment on this video
that's me doing it and I don't want to
lose that personal touch so that's my
current struggle but basically you asked
what my setup was so I've got a tripod
camera external microphone I record
everything myself I basically load up my
questions in advance on a computer or my
phone and then I record pop it into my
hard drive and then use google drive to
send everything to Christina it's about
20 gigabytes of video every week that
goes to her she's got a lot of sorting
out to do but that supposes right now it
works thank you for the great question
everybody watching if you liked this
video give it a thumbs up below please
leave a comment even though it takes a
lot of my time I love seeing those
comments come in it really makes my day
to leave a comment below you have a
question leave it below 2 i'll make a
video response and if you want to see
more videos like this click my face you
can subscribe to the channel thank you
so much I don't see you soon
you